-Thank you, and God bless.
Actually, one more thing.
Actually reminds me of a story
I once heard from one of my --
my friend Tim.
We used to call him
Duke Suitcase.
[ Laughter ]
That's funny, right?
-That's great.
-Yes.
-Should we just do it
one more time from the top?
♪♪
So, tonight is President Biden's
first address to Congress,
so we're gonna spoof that before
he actually does the speech,
which is always tricky to do.
To work on the impression,
we have one of our researchers
put together a reel
of speeches of Joe Biden,
and I will just play it
over and over again so I can
practice things he does,
little nuances, things...
you know, the way his voice is
and the way he moves his hands,
just so I can kind of get
a general idea
of how to do an impersonation
of President Joe Biden.
-Earlier today,
as was referenced,
I participated in the first
meeting of the G7 leaders.
-Tomorrow...
-It's about investing
in infrastructure...
-Got both of the hands.
He does a lot of eye wiping,
I will say.
-Remember that old proverb,
"For want of a nail"...
-Remember that old...
It's kind of like "'member?"
Almost like
he just got over a cold.
And he's kind of like...
He's very innocent standing.
He almost feels like one of
the Little Rascals or something.
Like he just ate the last cookie
or something.
-Workers and corporate leaders,
Republicans and Democrats.
-Ohhh...it's very nasally,
which is what I am anyway,
so I can probably do that.
He wears some decent
pocket squares
with little points
that I know our wardrobe
can knock out.
But let me just see -- let me
hear his voice again.
Like, which is...
-United States is determined...
It's like...all of a sudden...
[ Coughs ]
-...in the history [coughs]
of the United States of America.
[ Coughs ] Excuse me.
-[ Coughing ]
-You know, in this battle
[coughs] for the soul
of America...
-I just said that.
[ Laughing ] That's crazy.
That's -- Alright.
I think our take on Biden
has been
these kind of stories
that he has, you know,
that relate to the subject
that he's talking about,
but sometimes the stories
are too long
and a little bizarre.
You know, like,
"I knew a guy named --
who used to be called
Mississippi Jack.
And -- And he would -- He'd --
He would climb up a flagpole
and -- and stand next to it
horizontally,
and he could hold -- and he
could pretend he's a human flag.
And we would all go out and --
and salute him."
Something that bizarre.
Of course, he doesn't do that,
but that's the whole joke of it.
I've been watching this, like,
for an hour.
It's 1:30, and we have to do
the show at 5:00.
But we're gonna pre-tape this
probably around 2:30.
So, we have a good script.
I think it's really funny.
I got to get a wig and makeup
and all that.
-What's going on?
-Ah, alright. Here we go.
Step into
the hair and makeup room.
Here we go. And we're not gonna
fast-forward this.
We're gonna do it in real time,
so get ready
for two hours of great
behind-the-scenes footage.
♪♪
So much work went into it,
and you can't tell
when you watch it.
♪♪
Look at this,
it's already happening.
♪♪
When I was a kid, if you wanted
to get across a river,
you'd have to try a long jump.
I knew you would do
the pocket square.
I just knew it.
I didn't even have to ask you.
I knew it, knew it, knew it.
Yes!
Holy moly.
What? How?
It's just insane,
the attention to detail.
-We added the stripe
in the middle here
with ribbons to create
the same type of tie.
♪♪
-Hey, bud.
-You look great.
-Nice, huh?
-My God.
-Crazy, right?
-That's so crazy.
-[Speaking indistinctly]
-Alright, let's do it.
-Thanks, bud.
[ All speaking indistinctly ]
-[ Coughs ] Excuse me.
[ Coughs ]
-Like this, yeah.
-So, tighten up that background?
-At Addison Creek?
-Addison Creek, you said?
-Yeah.
We'd catch this big --
I don't know why.
-[ Laughs ] It's funny.
-Big -- Big catch.
Who could get the big catch
at Addison's "crick"?
Is it gonna be like, "And now,
President Joe Biden"?
-I think so, and then
we're gonna white-flash.
We're showing the best moments.
-Oh, I see.
-Would it be funny if,
towards the end,
we both stand perfectly still
with our arms stretched out?
Try to outlast the other.
Like, we act it out.
And then we just, like,
latch onto that.
-Yeah, that's funny.
We'd both stand perfectly still
with our arms out,
try to outlast Joe.
-Great.
-Good.
-Okay, great.
-How was it, how was it,
how was it?
Hey, guys.
-Great job.
-I think by the end
I kind of got better into it.
The character, right?
-[ Laughing ] The suitcase.
-Duke Suitcase?
[ All chuckling ]
That was Brad and Nick, but I --
We cut it out, but I'm like,
"We got to go back and do it."
♪♪
Alright, so we did the sketch.
I think I got there
more towards the end of it,
but now it's up to the editors
and the writers
and, you know, our producer
to make sure we have
the right takes on everything,
and then we'll play it in front
of an audience and see
what happens, see what sticks.
Alright, I got to go get ready
for a monologue.
Bye!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ We will rock you ♪
♪ You, you, you,
the legendary Roots crew ♪
-Earlier tonight,
President Biden addressed
a joint session of Congress
for the first time as president.
It was a great speech,
and in case you missed it,
we put together some of the more
interesting moments.
Check it out.
-Ladies and gentlemen, the
President of the United States.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Madam Speaker,
Madam Vice President,
members of Congress,
my fellow Americans,
tomorrow marks the first 100
days of my presidency,
and our vaccine rollout has been
a big success.
Over 200 million Americans
have gotten at least one dose,
and I tell you, modern medicine
sure has changed a lot
from back when I was a kid.
Used to be you'd go to your
doctor and say,
"Listen, Jack, I got my knees
all scraped up
trying to catch a big earthworm,
use it to get the biggest catch
over at Addison Creek."
[ Coughs ]
Excuse me.
Thank you, and God bless.
Actually, one more thing.
Actually reminds me of a story
I once heard
from my friend named Tim.
His nickname was Duke Suitcase.
-This has been the President
of the United States.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughing ]
What's he talking about?
Duke Suitcase?
Stick around.
We'll be right back.